so this is great this is this is a
really serious thing but it also
includes a really funny clip there was a
debate audience that broke out in an
uncontrollable fit of laughter when a
Republican Senate candidate tried to
claim that Donald Trump has been quote
standing up to Russia which of course he
hasn't been doing he's been doing the
opposite of that I'm gonna play the clip
for you and this is part of the sort of
Orwellian Newspeak where they have
straight-up started to say the opposite
of what is going on and this is now
leaking over to Senate candidates who
are trumpets including Republican Senate
nominee Corey Stewart who's running in
Virginia against incumbent Democratic
senator Tim Kaine and Tim Kaine of
course during the debate he talked about
Russian aggression during the 2016
election undeniable at this point he
talked about Russian aggression during
Barack Obama's presidency including the
invasion of Crimea downing an aircraft
over Ukraine here is how Corey Stewart
responded and of course laughter from
both the audience and Tim Kaine and
response it was noticeably silent when
the Russians shot down an Malaysian
airliner when President Obama was in
office he was noticeably silent when the
Russians invaded the Crimea when
President Obama was in office we have a
president who was standing up to the
Russians and now senator cane now we
have
now we have senator Kaine now we have
senator Kaine I actually think that a
straight-up uncontrolled fit of laughter
is a pretty damn good way to challenge
these types of nonsense claims it's
actually kind of powerful imagine if
when candidates say such ridiculous
things instead of trying to fight it
point by point when they've thrown out
10 lies in a minute and convince people
which you won't be able to do right if
the entire room simply starts laughing
hysterically at the obvious lies and
then you just move on it starts to take
on an air of this childish ignorance
from these people is so dumb and so
inaccurate that it's actually funny it
doesn't even require a response and this
is not normally my view right my view is
ad homonyms aren't arguments and you
need to take the arguments on at their
core but when the arguments are not even
based in fact and this is something that
over the weekend a number of interesting
articles were written in the context of
Holocaust denial and how Holocaust
denial should be managed on online
forums because you're fundamentally not
going to be able to actually fight it
with facts because the people who are
committed to Holocaust denial are not
going to be influenced by facts what
about just laughing and if they can say
it themselves right something like Trump
is tough on Russia without cringing or
getting red in the face how are you
going to convince them that they're just
simply wrong so maybe you do laugh off
the entire thing because it's an utterly
condescending way that could actually
show that there's a total absence of
logic and rationality laughter and
ridicule as the tactic instead of logic
and rationality and these types of
administration officials and candidates
they aren't based in logic and they're
not based on rationality so you can't
use those tools against them they care
about looking tough and acting tough and
imposing their view on others and
imposing their inaccurate views on
others so maybe just by laughing at them
you make them look silly and their ideas
hopefully go nowhere send me your
thoughts about the laughter technique
and do you think that it would be
effective not in change
their minds their minds aren't going to
be changed but in exposing the lack of
believability about the nonsense that
they're spewing to others to people in
the crowd to people who watch this stuff
on TV send me your thoughts about that